hello everybody and happy Halloween
welcome to another episode of top 5
Skyrim mods of the week I am of course
said forward annoying me is cam Robinson
hey Surya Sun in my tea camp these days
it's how I always sound cat I could have
sworn you had a more masculine voice for
now you have that's me you're thinking
do it you you thinking of I fell it I'm
not entirely sure what you're saying say
because you sounds so wet yep like I say
like usual although I do appear to be
channeling 3 c-3po this week
Seb it's time for our very first or well
it's time for out this year's Halloween
episode all right I think what you're
trying to say Seb if I could just
interrupt you there on you go is it's
time for our very first find a feature
that's right that's right
of the series yeah which this week it's
brought to you by me cam Robinson water
from Scotland oh that's where you're
from I hey I couldn't remember from Sean
and it's from major a meteor
what is major meteor have to say that
daughter it's you auditory I needed to
hear he was a doctor he is a doctor I
say sir he sent in this picture of the
world map rearranged it like a chicken
oh that's very good
Charlie goose with with this caption
saying the world's countries can be
arranged to form a giant chicken I think
you know what this means for your
argument it's very don't believe we do
cam it's great it's like saying the
world is a chicken so well you are
invalid I love it I love it I believe
the eyes color you know what else I love
so I am what ft your love said for you
handsome bastard well aside from your
face cam Robinson I don't know I think
your face is out there a your face oh no
no I always thought I will know sound
holidays instead of are you already
handsome man ever to come from Scotland
I do not believe that he's different
I believe that the case may be go
forward that you are
you don't know if you've been a specimen
well maybe but the number of ladies can
that are always asking me for your
number is insane but you know what you
know what they're also asking me for cam
why sighs they're asking me for mod
number one all right
all right step time mod number one so we
had to swap seats there I need to drive
and clothes yes I kept and clothes
don't forget the video very hastily SWAT
shirts yep yes we did
we sure did Abby know who never swaps
shirts with anyone said who is that's
Kevin Venoy I was gonna say Kevin well
you should just in case you didn't I
held on you should have taken a risk I
should have now Serb it's a Halloween
special Halloween so it's gonna be it's
gonna be a very scary spooky also look
to the right there's gonna stairs oh oh
there there Halloween Halloween uh
rhubarb's yeah duh Halloween all are
destructible undestructible mr.
Halloween arrows bobbles like they hang
on a Halloween tree they're very nice
said well yeah there might the mod
Halloween in Skyrim even more oh wow
can be even more pumpkins because last
year we had some now we have even more
anyway yes isn't he in B this is leaky
and this blue key and B at it it's I
love it it's really too saturated is
taking all the color out let it mix and
it's also added a healthy amount of film
green as well a lot of film grain I just
need to become a lady lady mode please
one lady please oh my god that's
horrific
isn't that just awful ah it's like the
Halloween face paints you see people do
when they put the zip these kind of O's
they're really good yeah they're really
the face a bit like that a little more
realistic
I was wondering Khomeini zombieman Nord
zombie van nerd
oh she's horrific she's she's quite
abrasive visually I like her though uh I
like that you can see all the teeth in
her smile is that one more right one
more which is just going to change up
the sound that we hear when we have
skeletons and I'm hoping that we will
have many scare you know what I'm a
Halloweeny adventurer I think we should
dare to show it up movies spawn in some
skeletons on this bridge I say do I
think what you need to do is maybe upset
them have an hour in the face
No maybe maybe you need to upset them
without killing them that's that but uh
normal
there it is what was that oh that's
pretty scary that's a certainly a little
worse whoa
good try pal you know much for Kevin
poet boys your epic macro but a really
even match
nice work zombie man or deal with alone
as well as the gnashing teeth yes in
fact she didn't even need to be
necessarily zombie ran Lord she comes
from Halloween face textures
unfortunately you do have to choose your
texture in advance when you download it
so you have no I want this face or this
face and they've got some Cinco de Mayo
style faces and various others but I
quite like zombie face for the true
Halloween spirit tell you what I love
the depth of field on the the bleakie
and be it's super powerful there's gonna
be an old lady face I hope so
that's that's great if it is that's
hilarious well say up we may have the
face for it but we don't have any
Halloween weapons until now what is that
weapon look like he'll do limbo memory
of fallen Souls yeah absolutely this
this is part one of three that we're
gonna be looking at but it goes right
here in modern number one start off here
we have it said not bad I would say that
is perfect for Halloween
I like the chains the chains you say I
like the chains I say I also like the
skull yeah very spike look too far
entirely suitable I think for Halloween
like if you turn up and out for
Halloween party dressed like this I
think that you'd be let in it's what I
think you'd go down a storm I think
there we go if I'm gonna take another
loud screen grab I onward one number two
welcome buddy to Mach number two which
is headless horseman Halloween special
part two we're hiding behind a tree
because I believe there's a bit of lore
to this mod that you might want
enlighten us oh there is the horseman
was a he's seein artilleryman who was
killed during the Battle of White Plains
in 1776 he was decapitated by an
American cannonball that is unlucky that
is unlucky it was American did it have a
flag on it in Tamriel of all places to
be killed by an American cannonball each
Halloween night he rises as a malevolent
ghost furiously seeking his lost head I
wonder where he is I wonder if I wonder
if this guy this guy knows where we can
find him we can all scam me headless all
God it's a headless horseman
I like his head he does have a head
bring the pain bring it Wow who's who's
firing arrows at you I mean I like that
they are but I'm wondering here it is is
they are they aiming the arrows oh this
so did you travel I see we do oh yes Oh
even get a kill me thank you see you're
lying you killed him so hard the kill
move didn't even work oh there's another
headless yours heads heads yeah yeah
heads well perfect fighting a headless
horseman to see if it'll take other
heads harsh truth hang on that guy's
back up I think he's so dead he forgot
to die that's warrior I genuinely think
you've over killed him no okay he's
remembered he's remembered that he
should be dead yeah he's bad right hit
him less hard this time never on your
feet man on your feet
I think he killed him I definitely did
kill him let's try and drag him out oh
god oh no oh you've lost him again that
he's in the long grass
there you go like a raptor we all have
got the key we've got the key we've got
his key but he is not himself wearing
any uh army armor he's not carrying any
weapons which i think means that we can
use the key to go and get ourselves some
sweet sweet loot where hellooo where do
we go I have no idea requires key oh you
mean this key the key that you've got ax
of the headless horseman very nice that
was pretty cool I bet that would kill
things I'll be yonk in that boots
horseman boots dark pumpkin head we've
got many head options
alright leave out our face is already
beautiful you're a zombie my nerd
so that that's just the attire it's very
smart I mean it's a little bulky for her
yeah yeah she doesn't quite such a beer
belly
no she's summer slender than that and
she is a credit for me here's the dark
pumpkin head which oh I do like that I'd
also quite like that that's pretty good
um the the rags II pumpkin hair does the
guy he killed him in it I think more
seasonal so yeah yep and no head that
just looks like a bug ooh an in ah must
be heads inside here I've heard this
place called many heads in hey friend
nice nice head I'm taking your heads
Oh fiery head you have a nice head and
if they're mine
haha a good head oh no oh oh using so
many as well she was a zombie heads make
me his beard also your heads I eat
little did he realize that oh oh no oh
no oh no so yeah I know Halloween as
well
nobody had so little time whoa oh that's
another mode I added said I got scared
don't be scared it's more number three
it is is it three a kennel loss kit is
it is three [ __ ] three I'd forgotten
that I'd also install the mod that gives
you real lightning it's real light near
your lightning I love it
the entire denizens of Tamriel while
Skyrim certainly are searching for a
headless horseman so you're right we
need to change our appearance and I
think inside this house and mod number
three which is called ghosty face
Halloween part three scream hmm might
just do the job it's a double door on
pal we've been fooled I'm not a bad I
was loved stealing for a bear course I
do it he doesn't need him yeah hang like
you're stealing from them surely there
are they still alive
they're owned I think someone owns these
burnt corpses I wonder who I'm gonna
guess he's upstairs
oh it's ghosty Frazee face but he's like
being on fire Connie's got a big night
huh he does so I thought that was a
sorta first now it is just a big butcher
knife
go pumpkin head gone ah on no you had a
good death squeal there good desk wheel
oh great we can just take his stuff
instead lease tab
oh man it's kind of like the sort of
Jerkins yeah yeah alright let's let's
switch it up this guy's obviously got no
criminal record at all so we'll be fine
oh wow yeah so the robe we can also have
an on I think there's an on bloody rogue
versus robe of ghosty face the sunshine
I think I like the science botheration
if we're trying to pass yourselves off
as not a criminal we don't want to scare
everyone immediately we want to sort of
lure them into assault like a false
sense of security and then then out of
nowhere stabby sad wonder if we can
enchant stabby stab someone oh do it
what with the hunk aid jerker O'Reilly
alright so you're gonna scare the hell
out of them but stop them from you
people it's level 25 flee for 30 seconds
and chest a paralyzed target for 5
seconds there's a chest paralyze them
well so they've still got 20 seconds of
fleeing let's say I bet the people of
Markarth are gonna wonder if they're
gonna give a trick or a treat
fools d face here yeah that would be a
bit of a gamble I'm gonna assume he is
all treat I think he's all treat yeah
let's let's go and give these guys a
treat an early retirement yeah you're
welcome you're welcome sir enjoy that
nap
trick or treat I think this guy's
featuring oh that's why the trick that
was the truth big trick here's the treat
do we wish you a Merry Halloween we wish
you a Merry Halloween we wish you a
Merry Halloween the decapitated head Hey
wow that was good I like that I was kid
ghosty face oh no only treats for you my
toget odds let's roll with your face
yeah that's better
who's happening really we did her a
favor
ah ha ha ha ha huh all right I heard him
talking earlier he was like my god I
hate having a spine I guess that's our
cue to run yes Jesus
sab welcome to mod number four which is
called Night of the Living mannequins
now everyone in Riften is going about
nuts
that's because these guys they finally
come alive come alive they sure have why
did we put swords in the hands of all of
the mannequins and don't hire City just
wanting my armor to look more realistic
great they died one down okay is he
carrying it come on ghosty face why am i
jumping ok well the guards are really
getting involved uh what a horrible
night for the entire towns mannequins to
come alive oh man they're well they're
being destroyed which is quite good they
are yeah good good work everybody
team effort team effort to get us done
there's a lot of guards here I kind of
want to get into some action leave some
of them to me there you go oh you're
American Direction work well I guess he
still is a mannequin mannequins
exceptionally weak in the belly yeah
I'll get this guy don't worry guys I got
him yo just the man in the ghost face
yeah I'll teach you to come alive and
thing well executed they're tired of
being slaves to humanity they are rising
up to kill the people of Skyrim prepare
to defend yourself no town or city is
safe and there are over 300 mannequins
for you to kill are you gold to tangle
niche ones so you get a little payment
for each one a little bonus so if you
were to kill all 300 you would be
rolling in some pretty sweet loot yeah
Sam I wonder if the mannequins have also
taken over Riverwood no I'm sure it's
sex unless I was a mannequin excuse me
sir Oh have you seen any Google
Americans have you would you stop trying
to at me I'm looking for some killer
matakohe there's so many of them your
skills sir our man akin to someone who's
rubbish a fighter and they a gaggle as
well wait I've got a plan
do your worst so we've got this luck
that way oh my god
there we go as the old proverb says if
you're tired is under attack by
mannequins ask a goat to clear it up I
never forget that one it's one my
favorites that was that was a bedtime
story that sent me to say many times
don't be bashful Fight Like a Man again
and the town is safe once again
well done go thank you melted Ghostface
Manzoor nneka's - dad um comfort the
children ha ha ha missing deliver bad
news effectively serve the man again is
dancing this this looks like a thing
that should be out of like a studio
ghibli ifeliz does don't worry I can fix
this
whoosh uh can you I said I can fix this
hey no no it's just breaking woman oh my
goodness what have you done where'd he
go
breakdancing man again I think it just
broke danced his way into oblivion I'm
sure he just ascended I think you did
Wow well there you go yeah that's what
happens when mannequins done and that's
how you open the gateways to hell
do did it do when goes face Wow watch
out is that the mod that is a mod sky is
angry sir it's furious at you doesn't
like Halloween and short why actually it
loves Halloween I think it's I think
it's angry because the show is entering
the latter stages it was number 5 it is
more number 5 and what's this one called
tab this one is called undeath I sound
cheery it is a full-on quest oh it's a
Skelly it is skeleton oh he's in a hurry
alright he's not bone he resisted fear
but he didn't resist death
alright let's get off shut him here and
see what we found here along the road
this lady is also dead oh I think
somebody removed her face and that's why
she suffered oh wait orders orders this
is what we want Seb sealed orders let's
read them let's break the seal that we
had the mages however and their unseen
pursuit of knowledge they cannot be
trusted or expected to withstand its
corruption stand our be with you so how
did he know that if he never broke the
seal a necromancer and the shoulders Oh
convenient uh wonderful
we checked the horse for horse order yo
he was [ __ ] dude uh no just hide hide
then we had one order and it was to hide
and he failed go Shadowmere go on
[ __ ]
we've got this guy you take the other
one good job hello a necromancer goodbye
necromancer
oh no USA I love ghosty face she's great
free stuff Oh human heart even though
one of those free necromancer's moon
brothers and sisters of the word huh
what good book doesn't start with
brothers and sisters of the worm I think
that's how my wedding pals are gonna
start brothers and sisters of the worm
we are gathered here today to join Hugh
to say two worms so said this quest is
quite a doozy I gather and we're not
gonna go into the whole thing
no it's quite an epic question see it's
been around since before last Halloween
as well we just didn't do it so uh this
one you may have already seen before
but if you haven't you will find out
together if it's as dark and dangerous
as it slows you start you want to go up
or down that's the question cuz I'm
usually ones that do enough stinger Stan
let's go kill this thing God that is
scary find it does catch you off guard
sometime
you know oh man he took his time for
that right through the skull I think
it's hey the key to tower basement
biggest key you've ever seen in your
life this looks cool what's going on in
here check the core check check those
corners yep those corners clear that
looks safe oh that's a great sign of
fate oh man I'm scared
activate trouble I'm sure this will be
ah okay that's all right dark pact a
deed I don't know what we just did
probably should have read the book first
yeah before doing the thing you mean you
don't just cut your own hand at the side
of any bowl they said we're not gonna do
all of the undeath quest because we
cannot want to leave that for you guys
at home to play just a teaser a spooky
teaser
yeah and that was really good I'm very
impressed with what we just saw it was
genuinely creepy yeah and the skeleton
siren certainly helped but do continue
on you know I at all interest in this
you have some awesome stuff ahead of you
including some transformation stuff with
some rituals you'll even be able to get
some awesome spells that will bring
forth folks from the dead a big area of
effect spell it's awesome
including being able to hunt down this
necromancer and decide if you want to
continue his quest for him or if you
want to destroy him and everything he
stands for I like to destroy oh well of
course of course so do make sure that
you go and check this out is a
wonderfully spooky quest sebsev there's
mannequins even in Whiterun not white
rhyme home Oh glorious I'm tired of
having to clean up all these mannequins
and oh god yards the one people that we
didn't mean were bill sorry pal I
thought you were mannequin so I think
we're gonna have to get some drastic
action here together if only there was
some way that we could remove all of
them in one fell swoop
whatever mannequins desperately allergic
to I don't know but let's ask this
chicken chicken good god that was quite
the answer you didn't even ask him
enough Wow uh that was a I like his
screaming face okay
no efficient alarm fix it fix it fix it
a film for boots okay wait wait oh hey
what if I just stand up in midair ah
gently does it
and we've landed I love this perma
screen it's great in a graveyard notice
how did I do you know what it did quite
well but there's still more over there
Venera this have another go excuse me
kind sirs if we just leave the met
I love that they attack the chickens I
hate everything now he stabbed himself
in the face he son himself in the feast
so hard they crushed that game and a
mass gain the meter swap seats and
closed again um SOI did that was the
hunt even Dorst
what a powerful crash now can it I do
believe it's time for the questions and
comments from me sep 4 are you handsome
bastard Oh shoosh sir huh
so the first comment we have for this
week cam um comes from Henry at hen JB
and Henry says apparently when the
guards say then I took an arrow to the
knee that means they got married
hey did you know that I did not know it
someone else had breezed that point with
me and when he came before I've
forgotten who that was and I apologize
to you mystery viewer cam no memories
not what it used to be all right sure
isn't not like Yura said we are
magnificent specimen of human male
achievement
oh dude cam shut up so cam if you want
to do the next comment I'd love to we
were also sent a large comment so large
in fact Elaraby large it had to be in a
photo form and I will read it for you
now oh do please do you can't fix the
locker mods that solve the problem I
have been having in Skyrim my character
cannot provide for the wife Oh No there
is a distinct lack of any semblance of
domestic life in C Iram I want to be
able to blow up baby chickens as well as
chickens AV chickens to be able to say
hello to baby gherkins and Mama Jerkins
whilst I'm slaying
at the Jerkins in is that too much to
ask I had to insert this with a photo to
bypass the word hehehe you cheeky little
scamp that was smart that was using the
old noodle
I began cam you're saying you're
sounding less like you're from your
native Scotland and more like a pirate
um I do believe karyn the most pirated I
mean save that most pirates originated
from Edinburgh Oh God cameras question
is for you I'm a gym rat so I couldn't
help but notice you look like you're in
pretty good shape
or it could just be the babyGap sharks I
I do like to wear a tiny little later no
i-i've seen the labels on your shirts
can don't be silly fat gently medium or
large I'm sure they're not but if it's
the first one how often do you work out
between all your projects taping the
show and gaming and do you hope to one
day look like Kevin van or Gannett
that's quite the question right your
response uh I would say that I own
average workout approximately three
times per week with my good pal Seb for
this I'm like your understudy at the gym
ah or equal in strength and looks we got
a lot of feedback from you folks saying
that you would come and see us live and
that was very encouraging yes very very
good
jolly good as we say from the Home
Counties where I'm from we're going to
do the Kevin van nord
choose-your-own-adventure yes yes before
we begin we do realise that we made a
small error as to how we should do this
we realize that if we want to both let
you guys come up with the the things
that happen but the story lies there's a
word come on Seb and also let you vote
then it would be every two weeks that
anything would actually happen and that
would be very slow progress Kevin Vinod
is not like slow progress so he says to
move ahead we're gonna let you guys to
continue to give us a story lines and
then we will choose Chris Shannon says I
didn't know if I tasted my blood or
someone else's I didn't know which way
was up I was sure it was time for
revenge I like how he's writing from
Kevin van Norden first-person mmm I do
believe that it's called a soliloquy yes
the second one you're so smart cam
Jude's owl Corps says my sentence thank
you
in a world where nothing responds
because of Kevin Van Nord I believe that
should be read in film voice which is in
a world where nothing responds because
of Kevin van Lord thank you for doing
that for me
Sora Smith who says Kevin Van nord woke
up in a field of daisies surrounded by
bodies with no memories and nothing but
the weapons and clothes on his back and
a note he had yet to read oh very
intriguing I like that one do you like
that one as well he bolted says Miss
rise from the cold earth born of blood
and Fire Kevin emerges from the belly of
the worldís Thunder heralds his arrival
and finally Oliver James suggests as the
first drops of rain descended upon
Riverwood Kevin looked to the sky
wondering whom he might slaughter today
decisions I've said but that's me said
what are you gonna choose me well well
cam it's a tough choice Ebola Tain's is
the most poetic Magda is my winner from
the day that's the first line of Kevin
van Knorr choose-your-own-adventure so
in the story of Kevin van nord it begins
like this
thusly mist rises from the cold earth
born of blood and Fire Kevin emerges
from the belly of the world as thunder
heralds his arrival so we ask you dear
viewer what what happens next
please write to us said how would they
write to us and they could tweet me at
ready seve go or me at come for as Rob
now I know that doesn't leave you much a
tech space to work in a tweet but that's
part of the challenge guys cuz um it's
good to constrict you with your and it
encourages brevity and good storytelling
whatever he says yes keep them short
keep him sweet you can use the hashtag
GS Skyrim yes or tweet them directly to
us we will be taking them from Twitter
however not from the comments cam I just
realized mine do a mod vote this week
that we does not it's Halloween it is so
as a special fear
what your winner from last week we will
feature the next week's show yes
everything will be returning to
normality next week I did a while
talking about camp where we will be
returning to perhaps different accents
if you are finding these diabolically
irritating oh I know I am I am as well
okay well I
voice hurts significant camp thank you
so much for being handsome and being
here as usual well thank you sir for
being mighty in all things especially
your knowledge of science and greatness
but that's you can now anyway anyway
okay and thank you guys for watching and
we'll be back next week for more top 5
Skyrim mods of the week
you